have you ever been turned down by a
woman and seriously yeah you have yeah
you mean you can't told me said I'd like
to go out with you on a date or
something end it and she said now I'm
not interested in you you know it's more
that like I've kind of like what I'll do
is I'll test the water with a certain
with it with I'll test the water with as
whether there's any interest and if I
don't get anything back for whatever
reason I'll kind of I just won't and
there are times you don't get anything
back yeah and sometimes I'm like I
mostly like what I'm looking for is hot
right or something or something that I
can go okay there's I could have like
there's a can I could have a heart
connection you know with my mom and
stuff it was always for me it's like am
I gonna feel the warmth of somebody in
some way when you go through a divorce
are you shy about getting marriage in
other words I went through a divorce
yeah and then you go never getting
married again that's it because I'm good
at this and it's never gonna happen
yeah yeah no I we had a we Miranda's
like you know family and get a lot of
child yeah I mean she's we have we've
always had a great well I like I always
was like listen you know we're gonna be
in each other's lives for the rest of
each other's lives we have a childless
whatever it takes let's let's let's you
know and it's not always easy you know
there are things where you know it's
like you know scheduling issues cuz
she's got it sewing you know listen my
son has got like Evan Spiegel as his
stepdad my Mike like the titans of
industry around at the supermodel and
Katy Perry is is you know it's like I'm
just like we needed him in therapy right
now right now